this is a production of cornell
university
yeah today i'll be discussing our work
on using deep learning to monitor and
forecast vegetation growth
and i just want to confirm that yeah i'm
a computer scientist so my knowledge of
prop science or agronomy is quite
limited but i'm definitely trying to
learn
and as well if you have any questions or
you're confused about some of the
technical aspects feel free to stop me
and ask questions
cool so i guess just a brief outline so
in this talk i'll start by introducing
why crop monitoring matters and then
i'll give a short introduction to some
of the key ideas behind deep learning
then i'll dive into a project in
collaboration with ying sun's group on
resolving sif or solar induced
chlorophyll fluorescence
at extremely fine resolutions using
remote sensing data with a technique we
call coarsely supervised smooth units
next i'll discuss a project with ariel
ortiz bubez group on forecasting crop
yields using a graph neural network
approach to capture spatiotemporal
correlations
and then i'll conclude with some general
thoughts and future directions
okay so why does crop monitoring matter
well i'm sure a lot of you are aware but
just to reiterate so if we know in
advance that a crop failure is likely
we could organize aid efforts to help
prevent food insecurity and famine
and at a national level
yield predictions can help inform import
and export decisions so governments can
know how much food might need to be
imported
at a local level farmers can also use
these yield predictions or monitoring
reports to make better management
decisions
also seed companies need to be able to
predict the performance of new hybrids
under various environmental conditions
so on top of this climate change is also
having a huge impact since crop
production is extremely sensitive to
fluctuations in climatic factors such as
temperature and moisture
and climate change has already reduced
agricultural productivity growth by
about 21
so it's less critical to monitor how
vegetation is reacting
okay so how is this currently done in
practice
well a lot of crop forecasts in the u.s
still depend on field surveys where
experts go into the field and observe
how the crops are doing
farmers can also provide their opinions
about growing season conditions
and this is great because experts
clearly know a lot
they have a lot of experience and they
can directly observe the conditions on
the ground
unfortunately this also requires
significant human effort and cost to
collect this data so even in the u.s i
think the usda generally only publishes
forecasts every month
and in developing countries this type of
data is even more inaccessible
and it also involves subjective opinions
on the other hand there are also these
crop simulation models which provide
more process-based mechanistic
simulations of crop growth
so there's a lot of really cool
scientific knowledge in these models
but they're not perfect they can produce
pretty biased predictions they require a
lot of assumptions about management
practices
and are computationally expensive
so i won't really go into these models
in this talk but integrating these
mechanistic models into machine learning
to provide more prior knowledge could be
an interesting direction for future work
okay so we discussed
field surveys and simulation models so
why might machine learning be useful
here
so we know that crop performance is a
really complex function
of weather soil conditions moisture and
a whole bunch of other factors
machine learning can actually learn
these complex relationships from data or
at least we hope
and figure out which variables are
relevant
and a lot of this data is already being
collected in real near real time such as
with satellite images or weather station
reports
and we have this massive amount of data
that's coming in we need algorithms to
be able to kind of make sense and make
sense of and analyze this huge amount of
data
and hopefully since this data is already
being collected in near real time
ideally we could detect issues before a
human is able to detect go into the
field
okay so now i'll give a really brief
introduction of some of the key ideas
behind deep learning i know i don't have
much time here so i'll just try to give
the basic intuitions
so the idea behind what's called
supervised machine learning
is basically just to learn a function
that can take an input and map it to an
output
and sometimes we can actually write down
this function like we know the
mathematical formula
but if we don't know this function
we might hope that we could learn this
function from
observing a lot of data
okay so
in the supervised machine learning
setting we have a bunch of training
examples
so each example is a pair of an input
and an output
so basically the algorithm is trying to
learn how to use the inputs to predict
the output
so you have the input here and then the
function f is trying to take an input
and predict what the output should be
let's just quickly cover some examples
of how this might be useful
so in everyday life if you've used email
you've probably actually encountered the
spam detection algorithm
which can take an email and try to
classify if it's spam or not
in image classification
you take an image and you want to
predict what is in the image like a
person dog car etc
and this sounds very basic but it's
actually a very critical building block
if you want to have any system
that can perceive the world such as a
robot or a self-driving car
and moving on towards examples more
relevant to plant science
so in plant disease detection
you might have an image of a plant leaf
and you want to be able to identify if
it's diseased or healthy and like maybe
even what kind of disease it is
in land cover classification we might
have a satellite image of this region
and we want to know
what parts of the region are covered by
different land uses such as farming
grassland urban uses etc
and finally in crop yield prediction
i've mentioned this so basically let's
say that we have a bunch of data about
weather soil
environmental conditions and genotype
etc and the goal would be to forecast
the eventual crop yield
okay so as you've seen as you've seen
these inputs and outputs can pretty much
be any form of data like text images
vectors
videos like
and any kind of data you have like
probably some people have attempted to
use machine learning on this
but just to start with a very simple
example
let's just say that you have a vector
of some numeric variables that you
observe
and you want to predict a single number
as the output
yeah so kind of the most basic approach
you might be familiar with is linear
regression
so you might be asking is linear
regression really machine learning and
you can actually argue that it's one of
the most basic machine learning
algorithms and it's also a building
block behind more sophisticated deep
learning models
so just briefly in this linear
regression setting
let's say that we just have two input
variables
so like the july average high
temperature in july precipitation
and we let's say model the yield as a
really simple
linear function of these two inputs
yeah so here we have the f of x the
yield
as just the linear function of these two
input variables
and so the algorithm
has to learn the weights or the
coefficients
that produce the most accurate
predictions on this training data
okay so this is great if your function
that you want to model is actually
linear
but a lot of non sorry a lot of real
world phenomena is non-linear
so what do we do in this case
so it turns out that just stacking
multiple linear functions is not enough
because that will still produce a linear
function
so however
a key insight from a long time back
is that if we use non-linear functions
between the linear functions
this can allow the neural network to
approximate
almost any function to a high degree of
accuracy
so basically again we still have our
kind of linear function on the left here
so this gray node is basically taking
this linear sum or sorry the weighted
sum of these inputs
and the only change so far is that we
just add a non-linear function at the
end of this
the non-linear function can really be
anything here this is a sigmoid which
kind of is convenient if you want to
squash the
number to be between zero and one
and of course nowadays in neural
networks relu is more common i won't
really go into this there's just a bunch
of different non-linear functions you
can use
okay
so now recall that each of these gray
nodes
basically
uh
yeah takes the
linear weighted sum of the inputs and
then passes it through a non-linear
function
and then the idea is that we actually
use the output of these brain nodes
as the input
for another linear layer
so basically we just stack
a bunch of these linear layers together
where the final layer is kind of
computing a linear function
of the intermediate values
so the result of this is just a complex
non-linear function
whose weights can be learned from data
okay so how are these weights or
function parameters learned
so i won't get into this in too much
detail but basically
there is an algorithm called back
propagation that can do it
so intuitively what it's doing is let's
just start with some really random
weights
so the function is outputting a
completely random garbage prediction
and we want to just compute the error of
this prediction this random prediction
against the true value that we
want to infer
so obviously this error will be really
large if the predictions are just random
but the key idea is that we can actually
use calculus
to figure out how to adjust the weights
in a way that can reduce the error
and specifically it's actually computing
the partial derivative of the error
with respect to every weight in the
function or the network
using the calculus chain rule and
uh you could actually probably compute
this by hand if you wanted to if you've
taken calculus but thankfully nowadays
the software can compute this
automatically
okay so then we just adjust the weights
they're kind of like little knobs that
you can turn in the direction that we
know will reduce the error by a little
bit
and then you just repeat this process on
a new batch of data
and of course the caveat is that this is
not guaranteed to find the optimal
weights but it's often enough to work in
practice
okay so
that's actually kind of the basics
behind how all neural networks work
there are a bunch of specialized forms
of neural networks for different types
of data and i won't discuss this in
detail but basically you can use
recurrent neural networks if your data
is a sequence like text or audio or time
series
if your data is more of an image that
has like local structure
you can use convolutional neural
networks basically these kind of learn
features from very localized regions of
the image
and can start to aggregate them further
into more
complex and abstract features
and this could also be used for video
data hyperspectral images or even time
series like
the number of dimensions is flexible
and then a more specialized form that
i'll discuss today is called graph
neural networks
and it's useful if the data has a graph
structure of nodes and connections
the obvious example is social networks
an example that we'll use today is
counties in the u.s
where each node is a county
and then the connections between
counties represent the fact that these
counties are adjacent or somehow linked
okay so that's kind of the basics behind
deep learning uh some pros of deep
learning are that the functions that it
can learn
are extremely
expressive
and they could in principle learn almost
any function so they work really well
for a lot of tasks like machine
translation image recognition speech
recognition protein folding etc
but the downside is that neural networks
typically require a lot of data to train
on
so if there's not enough data they can
often overfit by essentially memorizing
the training data set
so think of this as just like you
memorize the solutions to the answer key
on the homework then this is not going
to help you actually learn how to solve
new problems
okay so
to avoid this we often use a held out
validation set to think check if this is
happening
stopping training early is often enough
to prevent overfitting you basically
have this just
held out validations that they don't
train on and you can see how well it's
generalizing
and it's also hard to interpret how the
neural network makes predictions this is
an area that's actively being researched
but it's still kind of tricky
okay so if you're interested in learning
more about machine learning there are a
bunch of resources such as this cs5785
course taught by
vladimir kulishov whose videos are
actually online on youtube and there's
also this intro to ml class whose videos
are also online
but if you just want to quickly start
coding and you don't have time for a
class you can also try for example
pytorch's tutorials
which pytorch is one of the most
commonly used deep learning frameworks
nowadays and you can get started pretty
quickly
okay are there any questions up to this
point on the basics
cool
okay so now i'll discuss this project
basically on monitoring vegetation using
sif solar induced chlorophyll
fluorescence
at extremely fine resolutions
so this paper was recently submitted to
this ichikai 22 conference and a short
version was accepted at the europe's
tackling climate change with machine
learning workshop
okay so some of you might be familiar
with sif already but basically just to
motivate what it is
the goal again is here we want to use
satellites to monitor vegetation or crop
growth from space
so a lot of work uses vegetation indices
such as ndvi
which are simple combinations of a few
spectral bands
by contrast
uh solar-induced chlorophyll
fluorescence unlike ndvi
actually has direct mechanistic linkages
to photosynthesis
so we can directly sense photosynthesis
that is going on and it's thus better at
vi's at predicting crop yields or other
crop monitoring tasks like detecting
heat stress and drought
but the problem is that sif
is actually a very difficult signal to
measure from space
so existing satellites tend to produce
quite noisy data and can only capture
about three kilometer resolution at most
and even these course resolution
measurements have pretty limited
geographic coverage
so within a large area such as many
square kilometers
sith can actually vary dramatically
between farms due to crop type
management practices and so on
so our goal is to predict sif at a finer
resolution so that we can kind of detect
differences between individual fields
okay so this is a test that we call a
forcedly supervised regression it's also
commonly known as downscaling in a lot
of literature
so basically if we want to predict stiff
at a very fine resolution
we can use fine resolution satellite
imagery from landsat
plus some other features
so our goal
is to learn this mapping from the fine
resolution features
to the fine resolution sif
however
the twist is that during training
we only have access to course resolution
sift labels that are at a much coarser
resolution
so we actually don't really have fine
resolution labels to train on
so we call this problem forcely
supervised regression where
like we have this input tile of features
that's at a fine resolution
and we have like the course level sif of
the entire tile
so we actually want to infer what is
stiff at each of the individual pixels
in the image
so this task is really difficult and
underdetermined but even if you know the
average sif the whole tile is 0.6 there
are like a nearly infinite number of
possibilities for pixel sifs that
average to the correct value
so it's not a traditional supervised
learning problem
so to address this you kind of need to
introduce some inductive biases
such as localization this one is pretty
obvious like each pixel sif
should only depend on nearby pixels
features like it doesn't really make
sense if you want to predict if this
pixel
to look a few kilometers away at other
areas
and then there's also
smoothness
so this is kind of implicit that we're
assuming that pixels with similar
landsat reflectance
and land cover type
should correspond to similar sif
so of course like if the features don't
really explain sift double then you
wouldn't expect the model to perform too
well
let me just check if there's any
questions okay
um
okay uh
yeah so i won't go into this basically
this these plots kind of show that this
assumption that similar reflectance
is often correlated with similar sif
folds
okay
so how is this task often done currently
a lot of bass lines use a very averaging
based approach
where during training they train a model
at a course resolution by just taking
the average of each feature or variable
across the entire tile
so like here we have the average
reflectance band 1 reflectance band 2
temperature etc
and then given all these averages across
the whole tile
you can kind of train some regression
model like a linear regression or neural
network to output the sif of the tile
and then
if you want to predict at a fine
resolution
you could just try porting this model
over to the fine resolution data
but the problem is that
during training time
all this spatial variation in the tile
is lost
and in particular these tiles are
usually mixtures of a bunch of different
crop types or farms
so
that we may not even know uh from the
data sets like how an individual
homogenous field should do
okay so an idea that we introduced here
is to use a neural network called a unit
so basically unit is commonly used for
tasks where we want to output a
prediction for each pixel in the image
so this is commonly used for image
segmentation and so on
the key idea is that this unit
is capable
of
producing a predicted sif for each pixel
and it maintains localization
such that the predicted sift for each
pixel
really only depends on the nearby pixels
features
and again like this model does not need
to look at fine resolution sift labels
during training
okay so kind of a basic idea for how to
use this
would be like we have our original input
tile
we just pass it through some
pre-processing augmentations
and get a
another pre-processed tile
then we pass this tile of satellite
imagery and other stuff
into the unit
and the unit can output predicted
for each pixel
and how does this model actually learn
well
one constraint that we can use
is that
the average of our pile sorry our pixel
sif predictions
should be about equal to the true tile
sif
so recall that we know that the true
average sif of this whole tile
should be some number like 0.6
and our goal is to output pixel
predictions
that match to the true value
but of course this is not quite enough
yet because
as i mentioned there's like an infinite
number of pixel sift predictions that
could produce the correct average
and in particular
we observe that sometimes the model
can often produce really extreme
predictions
that still produce the
correct average
for example here this model is thinking
that some fields are super high and
super low safe
and they still average the correct value
but uh the predictions for individual
fields are not super accurate
so to avoid this issue we actually need
some kind of regularization
so basically we're trying to ensure
that similar farms have similar
predictions
by similar farms we mean that they have
similar kind of landsat reflectance
values and other features
yeah so basically
how we modify this is
we i guess we can add the smoothness
loss
that basically serves to encourage
pixel pairs with similar input features
to also have similar sif
so we just sample random pixels that
have the same crop type and try to just
enforce like
if they have similar reflectance and
crop type they should have similar
yeah and this turns out to work pretty
well and in fact the smoothness loss is
actually not so critical because
if you have
the fine resolution validation set
uh you can actually just stop the
training early before it overfits and
then that will also produce a good model
okay are there any questions on kind of
this point up to this point
okay
so i guess just to quickly recap what
data sets we use
so we have like
input features such as landsats fldes
land data and land cover masks
and then for the sif labels
during training time we use coarse
resolution sift labels such as a three
kilometer resolution from oco two and
cephas
and during model selection and
evaluation we use a very small
validation set of a few fine resolution
sift labels to kind of test the accuracy
of the model's fine resolution sift
predictions and kind of determine is
this model even on the right track or
not
so just in general the results are
pretty promising
in that our model
outperforms a lot of other competing
approaches by the reasonable margin so
like here our model has a
normalized ruby squared error of about
18 percent of the true sif
uh the true average sif whereas others
are above 20 percent
uh so yeah just in relative terms it
outperforms baselines by
reducing the root mean squared error by
about nine to ten percent
and this also holds even if the tile is
completely unseen
and also
across multiple resolutions and crop
types
so here's just an example of what the
model can output
so on the bottom left here
this is the actual ground truth
fine resolution sith map
and the top left
is kind of the satellite image that the
model takes in as input
okay so
basically the three columns represent
predictions for different algorithms
sorry the the bottom row is the actual
predictions and the top row is the
yeah is the
error of these predictions
and while it's actually pretty similar
but you can actually see that
in our model which is the furthest right
uh the predictions tend to be
slightly closer to the ground truth like
there are fewer dark red or dark blue
pixels and more of them are yellow which
indicates more accurate predictions
okay so just to conclude this part of
the talk we developed this method
coarsely supervised smooth unit which
can predict stiff at a very fine
resolution even when only course
resolution sift measurements are
available
and due to localization properties they
can figure out which farms have higher
lower sif
and we need to use some regularization
methods such as early stopping and the
smoothness loss to ensure that similar
pixels
mapped similar sif
so hopefully this fine resolution sith
estimates could facilitate improvements
in crop yield prediction and monitoring
and
hopefully this might be generalizable to
other related problems such as
predicting soil moisture and
evapotranspiration at fine resolutions
well any questions up to this point
i just ask uh
on the uh
ground truth data is that mdvi
good question so the ground truth data
actually comes from an airplane it's
from the cephas data set
so this is only available for very
limited farms so we can't like use this
everywhere but it's just a validation
to see if our predictions are even close
so it is data yeah it is stiff measured
from an airplane
running out of time so i'll just briefly
discuss our other project on
uh harnessing geospatial and temporal
information in crop yield prediction
okay so our goal here is again
now we actually want to forecast real
crop yields in advance
given some weather and environmental
data
and it would be nice to do this in the
middle of the growing season such as
before well before harvest
so there's a lot of work applying
machine learning to this problem before
i won't go into this but basically
a lot of this assumes that each county
is independent
and they do not take advantage
of geospatial correlations or just
correlations between nearby counties
in fact a lot of machine learning
methods assume that each data point is
completely independent of each other but
in here
nearby county's yields are actually
correlated they're not like independent
or identically distributed
so knowing features from nearby counties
in addition to the county that you care
about
can provide some important spatial
context
like for example parts of the county
near the border with another county
might actually be more similar to this
other country than the center of its own
county and seeing information from
nearby counties thus kind of provides
information
about larger regional trends
so in this project so far we've used a
graph neural network to model these
spatial correlations
where again the graph here is kind of
the adjacency graph of u.s counties
where
counties are nodes and
counties are connected if they're just
adjacent to each other
okay so we use a lot of different data
sets for this problem and just
pre-processing this was a significant
amount of effort basically we use uh
weather data like temperature
precipitation moisture and then we also
use this land surface model variable to
sorry land surface model data to capture
soil moisture at different levels in the
ground
we also use soil survey data to kind of
capture the long-term characteristics of
the soil in a particular region
so we pre-process this by converting all
the
time varying features to weekly
and then computing the average of each
feature for each county
okay so our method briefly
so i'll explain our method so
we start with just the input features
such as weather and soil data for a
particular county
and a sequence of five years
so why do we use five years well it
turns out that there's also like
long-term trends in crop yields such as
crop yields have been increasing over
time so we think that
using a sequence of five years might be
helpful
so we have these input features and we
first passed them
through an initial
set of convolutional neural networks
that can extract features
from this sequential data
so what i mean is
because for example the weather data has
a fee it has a value for each week
so
we use a cnn a 1d convolutional neural
network to extract features from this
like weekly time series
similarly for the soil g-servo data we
don't have a value for each week it's
fixed over time
but it actually varies across different
depths in the soil so we can also use
the cnn to extract features from that
okay so now that the cnn has kind of
extracted some useful information from
these sequences we use a graph neural
network to aggregate information from
nearby counties
so basically just briefly for a given
county you can sample the neighborhood
for nearby counties
and then you aggregate some feature
information from the neighbors
so basically the other counties are also
giving you some information about how
the weather conditions are in those
counties
and then finally once you've aggregated
all this information you can then
predict the final label or crop yield
for this county
yeah and then finally after this graph
neural network kind of aggregates
information from nearby counties we then
pass the output of this to through a
recurrent neural network and lstm
that can process features
from the series of years
and then it outputs the final crop yield
prediction
okay so generally the training procedure
we simply
do the usual where we compute the error
so the predicted yield versus the true
yield using this function basically just
the measure of how wrong the predictions
are
and then you back propagate this error
and adjust the model parameters to try
to reduce the error
and then you repeat
so we test this model on different
data sets such as corn and soybean and
years 2018 and
so if we test the model in year 2018
this means that we actually train on the
years up to like t minus two like two
years before
and then you validate the model on the
previous year which means
uh selecting the model hyper parameters
and like
validating it to make sure it works well
and then you finally tested on this year
t
which has never been seen during
training
yeah and basically these results show
that our gn and rnn approach outperforms
a whole host of competing methods in
terms of prediction accuracy and r
squared
and this generally holds across multiple
crop types and years
so just here's an example results of
like 2018 corn for example so
uh so this scatter plot just plots the
predicted on the y axis with a true
ground truth crop yield on the x-axis
and you can see that they're generally
pretty close to this line which
indicates accurate predictions
and here is just the map on the top is
the predicted crop yield using our model
and the bot in the middle one is the
true corn yield
so you can see that it's generally
picking up at least on some of the
geographical trends in which counties
have higher and lower crop yield
yeah and basically this also works
pretty well even at a
early stage so if you want to predict in
the middle of the year kind of a
very basic approach you could use
is just pick a date
and then after that up to that date we
use the actual features for that year
but after that date we present we
pretend that that's in the future
so after that day we just replace those
features
we remove them and just replace them
with the historical averages
so this is kind of like a pretty naive
method to do early prediction
yeah but using this method our gnn rnn
framework still generally does the best
okay so in conclusion on this part we
developed a gnn rnn framework to harness
geospatial and temporal structure for
crop yield prediction since we know that
nearby counties are correlated and share
information
this model outperforms existing methods
across a wide variety of crops and years
and hopefully these model predictions
could help us forecast the effects of
climate change and facilitate
humanitarian planning to alleviate food
security challenges
okay any questions on this part of the
talk
yes
do you normalize
out differences between counties i'm
asking this question because i'm from
the state of delaware and i'm aware of
that there are counties in this country
that are bigger than my state
right right so
that would lead me to wonder that maybe
bigger counties might
uh
smoothen out certain parameters that you
desire as compared to smaller accounts
right yeah so i guess that's a great
question uh
so i think the yield measurements were
after here actually in bushels per acre
so it is normalized by the acres of
farmland in the county i believe
uh
yeah but i guess yeah there are
definitely still a lot of intrinsic
differences between counties and in
future work we hope to kind of analyze
these more
another question um
how does it handle irrigated land like
nebraska has a lot of irrigated land
right yeah that's a great question uh
yeah currently we don't use this
information
but i think we do hope to add it in the
future because
yeah you're right that irrigated land
has very different patterns than
non-irrigated
land yeah so i think this is actually
one of the biggest
uh
yeah biggest issues that we want to
address in future work
sounds good yeah
cool i guess i'll just quickly end here
uh so basically
just a few general thoughts uh so we're
now collecting this massive amounts of
data about the world from satellites and
ground sensors and weather stations and
so on
so in order to make sense of this
massive amount of data we actually need
techniques to be able to understand
patterns in the data and then be able to
predict things about the world
so deep learning can provide a valuable
technique to do this
and it often shines on large labeled
data sets
but if there's not enough data then more
work research-wise is needed and my
approaches are kind of a step towards
this direction
so on the ai side some opportunities for
future work might include
integrating process-based crop models to
provide some additional prior scientific
knowledge
or better algorithms for domain
adaptation where like if you train a
model in the u.s and try to apply it
directly in an african country this
tends to not work very well because of
these massive differences in their
environment
so like hopefully you can develop better
methods for transferring this knowledge
over and adapting to these shifts
and there are also some
work that our group has been doing on
multi-output prediction we want to
predict multiple outputs simultaneously
and methods that account better for the
spatiotemporal structure
like our method is a good approach for
this but i think that there are
opportunities for future advancements
cool and on the application side there
are many possibilities to use machine
learning i believe in plant breeding for
example where we want to predict
phenotypes from like the genotype
environment and management data
and for example finding the genes that
are associated most with a trait of
interest
and there's also some work on analyzing
hyperspectral images which might produce
additional data for monitoring
vegetation for diseases or other things
and
going back to the in first project we
could potentially downscale more
variables
such as soil moisture evapotranspiration
biomass carbon sequestration levels etc
by just
hopefully predicting these at a finer
scale could improve our understanding of
climate change or help inform better
decisions
and i want to thank my wonderful
collaborators
including uh yeah jamming who's here and
a lot of other yeah d jamming dreamwin
and jiren like for just a lot of help
on the technical aspects and dataset
collection as well as the professor
yingsun
uh ariel ortiz pobaya and my advisor
carla gums
and here are some of the funding sources
and acknowledgments
and references so thank you very much
[Applause]
for non-computer scientists i learned a
lot um
so
any questions from
you
yeah thank you thank you very much that
was great i'm a soil scientist so
um bear with me with the questions that
i have
i was also interested in in the question
of scale and size of of the information
um and and you spoke a little bit to
that but
i know that um from soils and and
landscapes when we look at different
scales variability and diversity changes
dramatically not always with the same
rules
um
and uh and and so with with some of the
information you're locked into the size
of the information i understand with the
zip for instance it comes in a certain
aerial size other information like field
boundaries come in another size but they
can also change
some fields are big and in africa
they're tiny um and uh
and so i'm wondering whether you need a
fundamentally different ways of dealing
with these different sizes um uh when
when you
uh
when you when you go across the
landscape and the other question is um
can you are you trying to get also some
functional relationships out of that not
just being able to predict well for
a reason that you don't know but
actually understanding
what certain factors how important
certain factors are so that we for
instance can adjust management um
across the landscape not just predict
a great question so uh
yeah i guess um
to answer your first question about uh
the multi-scale
uh modeling i think that is
definitely a very important area for
future work so like there are some
neural network algorithms such as like
convolutional neural networks that can
kind of
model features at different scales but
uh it's still not very
intrinsic i would say like i mean what
these things do is generally try to
kind of
first analyze what's going on at a fine
scale extract some useful information
from the fine resolution data and then
kind of aggregate it further to provide
more
global information
uh yeah i think yeah figuring out how to
work with like data sets of different
resolutions is
kind of an active area of research that
is very exciting
and i guess
your other question on kind of getting
the functional capabilities
or sorry the functional forms of how
this process works i think
uh
yeah i agree that's very important for
scientific purposes
yeah so i think uh
in general historically machine learning
has not been the best at doing this but
there is a lot of work on more like
explainable
machine learning algorithms that
can not only predict crop yield but also
kind of try to explain like
what variables it actually used to make
this prediction and
like why it made the prediction it did
uh yeah i haven't actually
dived into these too much but i think
there is a lot of active research on
this topic just some dimensions you
mentioned
any other questions
so for your first project we're using
the
um if i understand this correctly it
seems that the novelty
and the success that that method brings
is due to the fact that you can make
connections
within at the pixel level between
different pixels
have you quantified
how well
the
algorithms are for you to declare those
connections
and compare that
the success of those algorithms with
your output or your predictions like for
instance let's say your
algorithm that says that these two
pixels are related because they're of
the same
farm size you can say that algorithm is
85
efficacious but then your final sim
prediction might be
uh 60
successful
um how can you quantify the differences
between
this
right
predictor
prediction
is that a concern
yeah i think um
i think so
yeah so i guess what you mentioned is
like uh
yeah because
we're taking advantage of the fact that
we assume that like
say farms with
a similar sif might also have similar
say reflectance values and
uh this is in fact an assumption from
prior knowledge that
we are kind of making and
uh
and the so the accuracy of the model in
turn will depend on how accurate this
assumption is and there are various ways
to kind of tweak the assumption
uh how strong it is um
yeah but i guess in terms of the
absolute accuracy it's also
it is somewhat hard to tell uh in fact
part of the reason why for example if
the stiff case
the r squared was not super high because
like 0.65 for example was
actually because of the noise in the
the true label that we're trying to
predict
so because the
airplane is the airplane sensors of
itself is noisy so like maybe the model
is actually doing better but it's
being classified as incorrect because
the actual measurement was noisy so
um yeah so that is a really interesting
question
to explore more but you are confident
that your reflectivity
uh
algorithm that connects two different
pixels that's
highly accurate uh actually i am
uh
yeah actually that part is a bit more
uh
uncertain actually like it's basically
based on just correlations that
i am inferring uh but in general like i
test for this by
like just making this assumption and
seeing like how well are the
fine resolution sift predictions
representing the ground truth afterwards
um
yeah like this assumption like i guess
you could definitely
tune it a bit but it's still not
uh completely foolproof like you can
still have like pixels that are very
similar
but actually they're a bit different in
sift because of reasons that are not
observed in the data sets
any other questions
yeah thank you thank you for for your
talk
um
it's more technical question what
computer language are you using or
computer languages and what the kind
what kind of this deep learning uh model
still run on a reasonable
lapto
like to run it on the server or do you
do it on the windows
great question uh
yeah so
in general most deep learning code
nowadays is implemented in python and
there are a lot of libraries such as pie
torch or tensorflow that can do this
um
yeah in terms of the computational cost
that is a big concern with modern deep
learning
models uh typically it's a lot more
efficient to run them if you have access
to a gpu
so the graphics processing unit
so in general like i've run most of my
work on a server that has a gpu
but you could run it on a laptop but it
will probably be kind of slow-ish
depending on the amount of data you have
is the biggest
factor actually um
yeah if you have like a small data set
you could actually run it on a laptop
enlargement will take a long time
the time series of
climate data and also aesthetic
um soil data of course both are having
spatially
firing
habits but how to account for inaudible
yield
so
but no features were included
in the uh you know moderate
and
i sort of understand
if you are only valid in the last
but because
you already
i don't know i just feel like
how you can really
yeah that's a great question uh
and you're right that we don't have a
great data set for the genetic
variation yet i would appreciate device
on this but uh basically prior
work uh just notices that crop yields in
general have been increasing over time
so there is like that long-term
uh
improvement and
uh
it tries to control for this by
actually what i didn't mention is that
this algorithm also takes the future in
uh representing the kind of average
yield of the previous year
yeah
because if you are using previous year's
yield predicting next year so that means
the genetic management information are
already
implicitly taken into consideration
right yeah but the invaluable case is
the weather information in previous
years your uh still like useful in that
context because you already have
previously a yield plus current years
like weather information then you can
probably already work with yourself
right yeah
uh
yeah that is correct i think we're just
choosing to
uh
we're actually effectively choosing to
predict the yield of every year in the
sequence uh but i guess and recently
we've been finding that you're right
actually like just using the average
yield from the previous year and the
weather for this year is generally
enough to output an accurate prediction
yeah
so that's right
yeah so
yeah if you can somehow account for
general information
there's one more feel free to leave if
you need to go but uh
let's see so
there's a question on uh so what is the
purpose of only training with course
data
why wouldn't it be better to train on
both fine and coarse
this is a great question so basically uh
we're trying to simulate the setting
where only course data is available and
um
yeah so essentially
uh
for sif for example like the fine scale
data is only like
very
it's only very limited in the amount of
area that it covers so
we're trying to actually develop a
method that can work only if you have
course even if you only have core scale
data
but of course like the more fine scale
data you have the better the model can
also train and it's actually very easy
to
change it so that you also train on the
fine scale data
um
cool and then what are the causes of the
obvious discrepancies in the corn belts
uh your method predicted
uh
more uniformly than the actual one it
seems like the adjacent counties would
have taken care of that
uh yeah that's a great question actually
so
i
can't say for sure but i think
my guess on what is happening here is
that uh
so in reality in 2018 like these
counties in the middle of illinois
actually had like extremely high crop
yields
that had never been seen in the training
data set before
so i don't think the model would
actually be able to
directly
learn that if it hasn't really seen
similar examples in the data it's
trained on but yeah this is a really
important uh limitation
[Music]
and yeah
is this model able to predict the
extreme drop here say finally
there's a huge um drop of field right
um if your data like from the 1980s to
now does not be a year like like
problems yeah
yeah that is a good question i think
uh in principle like
uh if you have seen an extreme drought
here it should be able to
uh understand the patterns behind that
uh but if you haven't then
i guess
it would be hard for it to kind of
kind of reason that like
this huge dryness will drastically
decrease yields if it hasn't seen this
in the data but uh but i think this is
an area that
we want to look into because uh
yeah it might be able to like
extrapolate but it's extrapolation is
generally pretty hard yeah
would be gives me an opportunity to
incorporate like a mechanistic model
right yeah
exactly yeah i think a mechanistic model
that knows that like droughts cause like
really bad
decreases in crop yield would be very
helpful here
thank you very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu